- [Voiceover] During the
dehydration experiment,
ethene gas and unreacted ethanol
passed through the tube into the water.
The ethene was quantitatively
collected as a gas,
but the unreacted ethanol was not.
Explain this observation in terms
of the intermolecular forces between water
and each of the two gases.
And just to be clear, what
they're talking about,
we can go to the original
setup that they gave us
at the beginning of this problem.
And what they're saying is is,
when they warm up, they'll react,
the catalyst and the ethanol in here.
Some of that ethanol gets
converted into ethene,
but not all of it does.
In fact, part of this experiment,
we saw that we don't have a perfect,
we have a 60-point-something
percent yield.
And so you have a combination
of ethanol and ethene gas
going through this tube.
It cools down, then it
goes through this water.
And they're saying it looks
like we're only seeing,
or we're primarily seeing,
the ethene gas here.
How come we're not seeing the ethanol gas?
And the reason, and I'll
just paraphrase it right now,
and then I'll write it down,
is that the ethanol gas
is much more dissolvable in the water,
because ethanol is a polar molecule,
water is a polar solvent,
so it's going to dissolve
much better in water
than the ethene, which
isn't a polar molecule.
So let me write this down.
So the ethene will kind of bubble through,
while the ethanol can actually dissolve.
So let's write this down.
So, whoops, having trouble,
all right, there you go.
So explain this observation in terms
of intermolecular forces between water
and each of the two gases.
So we could write ethanol.
Ethanol
is polar,
so it dissolves
in water
much better
than ethene,
which is
nonpolar.
And so we could say something like,
so ethanol,
ethanol
and water
will have hydrogen bonds,
will have hydrogen bonds.
Hydrogen bonds.
You could even diagram it out if you like.
The ethanol is right over here.
So you have your oxygen,
and then you have your hydrogen,
and then you have your C2H5.
This side over here, this is
going to be partially negative.
This is going to be partially positive.
Oxygen is more
electronegative than carbon.
The difference is less than
between oxygen and hydrogen,
but this is also going
to be partially positive.
Maybe not as partially positive
as on this side right over here.
And so when you have water molecules,
so if this is a water molecule
right over here,
where this was partially positive charges,
partially negative charges,
you're going to have the hydrogen bonds.
Hydrogen bonds.
And so the ethanol is going
to dissolve much better.
The ethene isn't polar
and will only have induced
dipole forces acting on it.
So let me write this.
Ethene,
ethene is not polar.
Is not polar.
And so, or I could say,
so will
only have
induced dipole interactions.
Induced dipole.
And maybe well I could say dipole,
'cause the water is polar,
and even though ethene
is a symmetric molecule
and has that double bond,
it has no net polarity.
There are parts of the ethene molecule
that are going to be a little bit
more negative than others,
in particular, when you look
at the carbons over here.
They're a little bit more electronegative
than the hydrogens.
And so ethene is not polar,
wo will only have induced dipole,
or I guess we could also say just dipole
interactions,
interactions, interactions,
with
polar water.
Polar water.
And so this is why.
So this is why
ethene won't dissolve as well.
Ethene won't
dissolve
as well
and bubbles through.
And bubbles through.
Ethanol dissolves.
Ethene bubbles through,
'cause it doesn't have strong
interactions with the water.